E
O
SEE THIS ON.
INSTEAD OF OUREADERS DOING THE
REONSIBLE THING AND SAYING
OKAY, LET'S DO OUR BEST TO TRY
TO FACILITATE A NEGOTIATED
OUTCOME TO ACTUALLY END THIS
CONFLICT WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY.
INSTEAD OF DOING THAT, THEY ARE
FOCUSED ON HEY LET'S JUST DO
SOMETHING, LOOKED OFF,ND
KNOCKED THE NO-FLY ZONE WHICH
WOULD NOT HELP THE UKRAINN
PEOP.
IT IS NOT GOING TO HELP THE
AMERIC PEOPLE.
IT WILL MAKE THINGS WORSE
IT WILL DRASTICALLY ESCALATE
THIS CRIS AND PUT OUR PILOTS
DIRECTLY AGAST RUSSIAN PILOTS
PUTTING US IN CONFLICT AT WAR
WI RUSSIA
PUSHING US TOWARDS THIS BRINK OF
NUCLEAR CATASTROPHE.
>> Tucker: SAVE UKRAINE BY
DESTROYING IT.
>> EXACTLY.
IRAQ, LIBYA, SYRIA
WE'VE GOT TO LEARN FROM THESE
LESSONS AND STOP THIS MADNESS.
>> Tucker: WE ARE JUST GETTING
THIS FROM THE STATE DARTMENT
PRAYER THIS IS A TWEET AND I'M
READING -- I WANT TO RUN IT BY
YOU.
"THE UNITED STATES DOES NOT HAVE
EMICAL OR BIOLOGICAL WEAPONS
LABS IN UKRAINE AND GO.
AN THEY PUT UP A GRAPHIC THAT
READ THAT THE U.S. IS IN FULL
COMPLIANCE WITH ITS OBLIGATIO
UNDER THE BIOLOGICAL WEAPONS
CONVENTION DEVELOPED.
I COULD SEE ABOUT FOUR HOLES I
THAT.
THEYRE TELLING US WE DON'T OWN
ANY BIO LABS IN UKRAI.
I DON'T THINK ANYONE IS
SUGGESTING WE OWNED BIO LABS
THERE, RIGHT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
BUT YOU POINTED TOVIDENCE AND
WE'VE SEEN THROUGH DIFFERENT
PARTS OF T WORLD WE SAW IN
CHINA HOW THE U.S. IS FUNDING
THIS RESEARCH OR THESE LABS TO
THE TUNE OF HUNDREDS AROUND THE
WORLD.
WHY?
THE QUESTION HAS NEVER BEEN
ASKED OR ANSWERED BY THEM.
Y IS IT?
WHY IS THIS RESEARCH SOMETHING
THAT IS SO CRITICAL AND NOT DONE
IN SECURE LABS IN TH
UNITED STATES.
WHY IS THIRESEARCH BEING
OUTSOURCED?
THERE ARE SO MANY DIFFERENT
ESTIONS HERE AND ALL OF IT
POINTS BACK TOHE RISK THAT
THIS IS POSING.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I FRESH
IN OUR MEMORIES AND IF THEY HAVE
NOTHING TO HIDE, WHY ARE THEY
TRYING SO HARDO HIDE IT?
>> Tucker: THEY JUST INVENTED
IT UNDER OATH YESTERDAY.
SO LET'S NOT LET THEM PRETEND
THAT THIS IS LIKE -- THAT WE ARE
CARRYING PRUDEN'S A GUN OR A --